problem is if you fight with an edged
blade I'll have to do fire fight with an
edged blade I'll have no one left to pay
me
then Robb Stark's head I'm going to
serve it to Sansa at my wedding feast
it's you is it
the other kids won't believe me your
brother is a killer your sons will be
killers someday
resorts and resorts there was only one
Scotch Polly Joyce my husband trusted
you and you repaid our faith with
treachery
didn't ask the gods what he meant didn't
need to Howard in you don't worry Harry
we'll explain everything when we get
back to headquarters
Shh not hearing the fedora don't call me
no fedora I wish I had enough poison for
the whole pack of you I would gladly
give my life to watch you what I said
last night
English woman with a sexy voice like
yours it's hard to believe you're waking
up alone he's wanting to grow the
tallest loom the brightest then one by
one sooner or later they all get plucked
my lord the fleet has moved out of light
speed
comm scan has detected an energy field
protecting an area of the sixth planet
of the Hoth system the field is strong
enough to deflect any bombardment chaos
isn't a bit chaos is a ladder
sorcerer called and a voice answered and
ever since that day I have hated magic
go out out there under the sky look
around
what is the saying distance lends
enchantment to the view which would have
given us more time to deal with Roberts
brother's
but now madness madness and stupidity or
one or nipple [ __ ]
that's what
caved in his breastplate
probably shattered every rib II head and
that's another thing enough with a
dum-dum my name is Fred Flintstone FL hi
n t stone de Ibaka so CLE God nicoia
Arika Vica post me your own boss Ferraro
would you shut up for once in your life
I said it was sorry I meant it and
that's all I got to say you understand
last time I checked we weren't married
or even related
so you better stop throwing your crazy
ass killed rummy quite fruit for the
damn boy job